[Music]
we are experiencing the greatest
technological and economic shift in
human history we need a way to help
millions of Americans transition through
this period and a universal basic income
is the best and most efficient way to do
that hello I'm Andrew yang and I'm
running for president as a Democrat in
2020 I believe I have the right vision
priorities and values to improve the
lives of millions of Americans seven
years ago I started venture for America
to train hundreds of young entrepreneurs
to build businesses in Detroit Cleveland
Baltimore and other communities across
the country together we helped create
thousands of jobs but during this time I
came to realize that technology has
already wiped out 4 million
manufacturing jobs in Ohio Michigan
Pennsylvania and other states and it's
about to do the same thing to people who
work in retail food service and food
prep customer service transportation as
well as industries like insurance
accounting medicine and law I saw so
much over the last number of years
traveling this country what I
experienced was I opened her to me where
I would walk through abandoned
neighborhoods and boarded up businesses
I have two young boys and I'm deeply
concerned about the future that they're
going to grow up in if we don't change
things dramatically they're gonna grow
up in a country with fewer and fewer
opportunities and a handful of companies
and individuals reaping the gains from
new technologies while the rest of us
struggle to find opportunities and
eventually lose our jobs and it doesn't
need to be that way under my plan every
American adult will receive $1,000 a
month free and clear paid for by a new
tax on the
that are benefiting most from automation
if we provide a universal basic income
Americans will be able to go back to
school move for a new opportunity to
start their own business and really have
their head up as they plan for the
future with your help we can make
universal basic income a reality
join us let's build a new kind of
economy one that puts people first
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
what a cool video that we just watched
we have an amazing episode for you we're
gonna be talking about universal basic
income aka the freedom dividend we're
gonna be talking about putting humanity
first over the markets our guest today
is Andrew yang Andrew thank you for
coming out of the show thanks for having
me on it's a pleasure to be here Andrew
you are a President presidential
candidate so we'll get a little
handshake we a presidential candidate
for 2020 Democrat yes we you are an
author of the war on normal people yep
which is actually a fantastic book I
really recommend going and reading that
book we you're also the founder of
venture for America over the last seven
years now you guys have been working on
teach us about venture for America
teaches about the last seven years teach
us about everything that's going on man
because this is the most important
moment in humanity's kind of coming up
in these next couple of decades brief
yeah and let's unpack this yeah so I
started venture from America in 2011
helped train young entrepreneurs to
start companies and create jobs in
Detroit New Orleans Baltimore Cleveland
Birmingham and other cities around the
country because I had this sense that
that we had too much talent getting
concentrated on Wall Street and in
Silicon Valley and not enough creating
new enterprises around the country and
what I learned during that period was
that we're automating away many many
more jobs than entrepreneurs are gonna
create in Michigan Ohio Missouri and on
and on it's like we were pouring water
to a bathtub that has a giant hole
ripped in the bottom and so then you say
okay like what the heck do you do about
the hole in the bathtub and Donald Trump
getting elected in 2016 what was a like
a giant signal to me where things have
gotten so bad with the decimation of
manufacturing jobs in Michigan Ohio
Pennsylvania Wisconsin which were the
swing states he needed to win we
automated way four million jobs in those
states automated away four million jobs
in those states
fifteen we automated away four million
manufacturing jobs and in those states
and around the country and if you look
at the voter district data there's a
direct correlation between the number of
industrial robots in a district and then
a movement toward Trump so this is all a
giant automation and economic shift
story and for whatever reason it's it's
like our media is out to lunch on it
where they talk it's like oh why did
Trump win like the reason he won is that
we've automated away millions of
manufacturing jobs and we're here in
Silicon Valley right now my friends here
know we're about to do the same thing to
workers and retail truck-driving call
signers pass food on and on throughout
the economy so yeah I mean it is like
you said at the moment this is the
moment for Humanity to come together and
start owning what's happening okay you
just listed the industries call centers
retail food service manufacturing these
driving truck driving all these
industries are 50% of these jobs of all
30% of jobs are in that are in those
categories and they will be automated by
2030 well not all of them but a lot of
them and yeah those five job categories
do comprise 49 percent of American jobs
getting paid about $15 an hour retail
workers get paid about 12 bucks an hour
call center workers 14 or $15 an hour
and these jobs are going to disappear
very very quickly the most important
times are ahead of us and you have the
plan yes most important times ahead of
us yeah well so as soon as I started
digging into these numbers I kept kept
getting hit by this policy that's meant
to be the countermeasure to automation
Universal basic um and one of the books
that I read that really influenced me
was a book by a guy named Andy Stern who
used to run the largest labor union in
the country the SEIU and so a labor guy
the biggest labor union leader of his
generation said the future of labor is
no labor we are screwed and we need to
move to universal basic income so I
found that very compelling because it's
not
some technologists in some lab being
like oh we're gonna automate away those
jobs the labor guy says yes we're gonna
automate away all the jobs so I had
lunch with Andy starting in 2017 talking
about his plan which was to give every
American a this is a slow this is a slow
automation as in for therefore there
being no labor whatsoever
that's no it'll be a slow process to get
to no labor but a lot of these
repetitive tasks manually repetitive
cognitively repetitive they're right in
the crosshairs of software yes yeah so
so it's totally the case that we'll have
jobs with us for a long long time and as
you're suggesting according to the Fed
about forty four percent of jobs are
either repetitive manual or repetitive
cognitive but again if you look at
retail manufacturing truck driving etc I
mean truck driving alone
the most common job in 29 states three
and a half million truck drivers 94
percent male average age 49 average
education high school or one year of
college and then another five million
workers who work in truck stops motels
and diners that serve them as they
crisscross the country every day so it's
like 8 million jobs
yeah like 8 million jobs and and it is
it's a real path to the middle class for
millions of low low educated you know
load skill Americans and so you don't
need to get rid of all the jobs to have
massive problems I mean even the Great
Depression you had unemployment levels
of 25 percent but as we're sitting here
today our labor force participation rate
has dropped to sixty two point seven
percent which is a multi-decade low in
the same levels as El Salvador in the
Dominican Republic almost one out of
five working age Americans men of prime
working age 21 to 30 have not worked in
the last 12 months the underemployment
rate for recent college graduate let's
slow down to 20 percent of of working
age males haven't done done a full-time
job in the last year yeah it's eighteen
percent it's almost one out of five
that's right and then and what was the
labor force 63% and sixty two point
seven percent is the current labor force
participation rate also a multi-decade
low that does not count
part-time work that's only full-time
work full-time
62% people are employed full-time yeah
that's right which is a multi-decade low
it's much lower than the norm it's
usually like 70% well it's not quite
that high it has historically crept up
to that high so what happened was over
history you had a labor force
participation rate that was a bit lower
though again where we are right now is a
multi-decade low women entered the
workforce post-world War two and then
the labor force participation rate rose
so what happens you had this giant arc
where it was men working and then women
into the workforce of the labor force
participation rate climbed and climbed
and then starting in 2000 when we
started automating away the
manufacturing jobs then the labor labor
force participation rate started
declining as essentially men left the
workforce that's on its way down further
and a lot of one of the counters to
where we're going with this conversation
is the frequent like there's going to be
more jobs is it just like the
agricultural revolution or the
Industrial Revolution and but the the
one of the main differences between the
two periods is that this is coming after
50 percent of jobs you know in total
plus the the retraining is not go to a
factory for six weeks and learn how to
retrain no this is how do you teach
someone to be a creative adaptive
problem solver in how many years does it
take is this even possible
do we need augmented reality immersive
skills I mean who's gonna do this so one
of the things that's that's tough is
like if you get to a point where you can
train someone to do this complex job
then you can get to a point where you
can get software to always do now you
know it's except for rare cases where
they're there is like you know someone
where you need human digits to do things
and there are going to be non repetitive
manual jobs with us for a long time like
cleaning a hotel room makes no sense to
automate that because a human person who
goes in can recognize where things need
to be in the stains and like different
things and it's also already yeah and
it's also quite cheap so you're
incentives to automate that process very
very low but you look at something like
truck driving the incentives to automate
Freight 168 billion dollars per year per
year to automate huge labor costs
equipment utilization fewer accidents
fuel so that's an enormous pot of gold
truck drivers and retail employees all
these different people and you have this
list in your book as well which details
this output humans have emotions and you
actually experience an accident as well
and you detailed that out in your book
where you were high on emotion as well
and then we have to sleep we have we
have hunger yeah we have a lot of things
we have a hotel so you get past a lot of
these things by having automation that
has just better perception than we do as
well taking over and in saving a lot of
lives in the process there's so many
things but you're you're you're
literally running on this for as a
presidential candidate you're running on
everything that you're unpacking here at
the table today and you're you're
inspiring future for people today to
start caring about it and for the future
generation to be prepared for this most
critical time now in humanity we are
going through the greatest technological
and economic transition in human history
and our political class is totally
asleep at the switch about it it's crazy
to me I mean it's like an elephant in
the center of the country just tearing
things up and like devastating
communities and taking a whole like
categories of livelihoods and making
them obsolete and our politicians like
hey you know who knows what's going on
like I don't know why that happened
a day over SC was on our show a couple
times the founder founder and student he
calls it the plane we're all on the
plane and the plane is the pilots have
fallen asleep and we're just being
chillin on the back of the plane sipping
wine looking out the window oh it's
going down but some of us our lenses our
vision we're able to perceive the plane
going down you know and so a lot of the
people that are perceiving the plane
going down are in New York and Las SF in
LA Seattle these different metropolitan
hubs where interestingly enough you
write about it in all these collegiate
graduates people from Ana spent
from Detroit and Cleveland and
Birmingham these the central areas in
the US as well myself included from
Sioux Falls South Dakota
I've migrated out to these technological
hubs I want to experience the network
effect I want to be around the leading
scientists and entrepreneurs and that's
why I'm here and we're seeing that
migration happen and these people are
now saying hey look around you this is
the major time that's coming up well we
know it because we're working on it I
have friends who are directly automating
away many jobs they know it it's in
their business plan they have the line
item they say we're gonna save you this
much money technology often sees human
labor as a flaw to be fixed and done
away with and ironed out so it's the
people that are working on it or closest
to the scene who will say look guys this
is not going to be some gentle
transition and even if you look at the
Industrial Revolution it had mass riots
and violence and popular movements labor
unions came into existence in 1886 Labor
Day was inaugurated because of riots
that killed dozens of people and caused
billions of dollars of billions of
dollars of damage I mean that's why they
have like Labor Day it's like oh snap
like you know laborers are freakin
revolting let's give him a holiday and
we instituted Universal high school in
1911 so an in large part because of a
response to what was happening so the
Industrial Revolution was really really
rough and this time is gonna be much
much worse according to being it's going
to require labor absorption at between
three and four times the rate of the
Industrial Revolution what does this
labor absorption well what that means is
that you have workers who are losing
their jobs we managed to find new jobs
and so the industrial evolution again
massive conflicts and strife and
according to being this time you're
going to need to somehow have
reintegration of labor at a much much
higher pace and if you look at the
numbers right now they're really
discouraging because the efficacy rates
of government-sponsored retraining are
between zero and 37% really bad I mean
37 is being very very generous honestly
because that's just one study said 37%
of people trained for this industry went
into that industry and so someone that
would have happened without the
retraining presumably
so we're terrible at retraining and
right now the rates of Americans moving
from one state to another for any reason
also in a multi-decade low so you have a
labor market that's not dynamic at all
and then you're saying hey it's time to
to have a transition happen at four
times the rate of the Industrial
Revolution I mean the odds of that
happening magically painlessly
seamlessly zero essentially and and our
government is again the sleep of the
switch where instead of putting to work
massive incentives or really empowering
people to be able to adapt we're just
hoping the market figures it out which
it will not and you you just set it a
little bit ago that that DC isn't going
to just come up and and and figure it
out that the tech hubs on this East and
West Coast are just gonna have to be
like yo we figured it out here you go DC
come and build it in but let's let some
hack I mean I was in DC yeah they
understand technology not at all and if
you saw the Zuckerberg Humes you got
that sense I mean you had these senators
who were being spoon-fed questions from
their staffs and they were still
embarrassing I mean and that's the good
ones though was yeah that's a good point
was when they were like you know will
you tell us what hotel you stayed at
last night it was like no that's our
fight
okay so let's unpack the campaign now so
yeah in 2020 we got an election coming
up this next election cycle for
president of the US and Uganda got these
three main pillars one of them being
this freedom dividend similar to
universal basic income and so there's a
value-added tax and that's the way that
this is paid for and so teach us about
the value-added tax and then teach us
about how much people will expect to
make how much how much they'll expect to
earn and then also what they can do with
this money how will stimulate the
economy all these interesting things I
mercy will provide for them oh sure
thing
so the freedom dividend is
Universal basic income by a different
name just test better so we're going
with the freedom dividend where every
American adult between 18 to 64 gets a
thousand dollars a month free and clear
you get it I get it
it doesn't matter if you're working how
much you make we don't care
you're citizen you're an adult that was
not as month now the cost of that is
about two trillion dollars per year now
for reference our economy is now 19
trillion and it's growing four trillion
in the last ten years alone we are the
richest most advanced society in it well
we can easily afford a thousand bucks a
month so the federal budget right now is
four trillion so two trillion seems like
a very big ad but the great thing about
it this is not a government program it's
just circulating money back to citizens
so that we can buy things for our
children repair our cars go to school
start a business whatever we want to do
so there's two trillion the way it's
broken up is that we currently spend
between five and six hundred billion on
welfare and come support disability etc
current welfare programs are about five
to six hundred billion dollars yes okay
so if you're going to give everyone a
thousand dollars a month but they're
already getting let's say a thousand
dollars in current benefits you're then
you say okay you're already getting at
your set okay okay and so this five to
six hundred billion decreases the costs
are the freedom and about twenty five
percent okay down to one and a half
trillion yes okay now the big change you
have to make is that right now our
income tax system is going to be really
terrible at generating revenue from AI
software machines because they're gonna
do more and more work but the
beneficiaries tend to be really big tech
companies that don't pay a really high
tax rate all you've wrote in your book
that Apple Microsoft and Google have
tens of billions to hundreds of billions
of dollars that they run through
offshore Ireland's a particular favorite
and so they they just have all this
money parked offshore because they can
easily just assign revenue to various
places and so even as the big winners in
this AI revolution make more money it's
very unlikely that the
US government or society's going to see
a lot of that so what we have to do is
we have to adopt a value-added tax which
is something that every other
industrialized country in the world
except for us so it's us modernizing and
getting with the program and because our
economy is so large of value-added tax
at half the average European level would
generate about 800 billion in revenue so
Europe's about 20 percent value-added
tax yeah and so what does that look like
then for like a company like Apple than
that so what would happen is that Apple
would be paying a value-added tax at
every step of the production process and
then there go up by about that amount
total about 20% more for a MacBook or an
iPhone would be about 10% though
traditionally companies end up eating
some part of that and then passing some
of it along to consumers so it could be
that that the price of like that iPad or
whatever goes up like 8% or something
along those lines but keep in mind
though you dollars extra a month and so
has everyone else and so everyone want
like the bottom 94 percent of the US
population will end up with an increase
in purchasing power but then the
question then is if you if the items are
costing more money if there is that
slight in violation of the of the cost
of the items then how much is that
offset this thousand dollars a month
that I'm making yeah it'll give me the
ability to maybe buy it but then these
normal items like food and water and
electricity are mmm have they how much
have they went up and how much does that
take away from my thousand that I'm well
it just depends upon how much you
consume and that's one of the beauties
of this system is that the average
American is consuming nowhere close to
the threshold where that weird the way
they would lose again the bottom 94
percent of Americans would see an
increase in purchasing power you need to
consume an awful lot in order to have
the VAT be more than a thousand bucks a
month and if you're at that apex of
society then that's great it's great for
you even the wealthy people I know and I
do know some wealthy people they prefer
consumption tax
regime to something like a wealth tax or
even higher income taxes because they
what they'll say is look I can control
my consumption I can get a slightly
smaller yacht or jet or whatever but I
can't control my wealth and so if you
tax my wealth it's gonna make me really
mad but if you text my consumption then
I'll be like yeah that's fine and again
every other major land industrialized
country already has it summit have twice
the level so this is something that
people are very very accustomed to in
data tax taxes consumption which is why
people are more okay with it
yes yeah and so value-added tax that
half the European level gets you 800
billion so that plus the five hundred
billion gets you up to about 1.3
trillion out of the two out of the two
yeah now here's the beauty of it is that
if you give people a thousand bucks a
month they're gonna spend it right now
fifty-nine percent of Americans can't
afford expected $500 bill everyone's
really cash-strapped and yeah living
paycheck to paycheck so with an extra
thousand bucks us included support on
patreon.com the link is below
yang 2020 yeah I mean let's do it it's
gonna help creatives artists
entrepreneurs the freedom Dibner will be
the greatest catalyst to
entrepreneurship and creativity in the
history of the world so you put a
thousand bucks a month into people's
hands they're gonna spend it they're
gonna create things and it's going to
create four and a half million new jobs
and grow the economy by thirteen percent
or two and a half trillion according to
Roosevelt Institute that modeled this
out so it's going to be this incredible
boom and the US government gets back
about five hundred billion of that in
new revenue because of the economy booms
by two and a half trillion of course the
government is going to get its fair
share so that gets you up to ninety
percent of the cost of the freedom
dividend and then you get the last
couple hundred billion from cost savings
to health care incarceration
homelessness services it gets very
expensive when people hit our
institutions yeah yeah there's one study
that showed that if you give a poor fit
one dollar it'll save us $7 so keeping
people functional with a thousand bucks
a month actually is going to be this
incredible value multiplier mental
health will improve graduation rates
will
is nutrition gets better like all of
these things that will be incredible
value adds and you know what goes down
hospital visits domestic violence
criminality like all of these things so
it pays for itself
and the what I'm suggesting isn't even
aggressive like you could say hey we're
really gonna like create this man which
we will but even if you're conservative
this thing's very affordable you listen
out some of these crucial economic
measurements we don't even take into
account right now it's good that you
know how you want to pay for this and
how to structure it to be paid for it
seems like a very we've had Zoltan he's
fun on the show before talking to us
about leasing out I couldn't believe
that was his real name like I heard that
and I was like man that's like wow he
like came up with his own like it's like
the most popular name in Hungary I heard
that and then I felt really bad I felt
culturally ignorant yeah because I was
like man he gave himself like some cool
name from the future but the transient
his name yes that's what I thought yeah
I was like Zoltan the transhumanist I
was like that's amazing
ya know it's but it's almost even more
basic that it's just actually a totally
normal high dairy baby shows what I know
yeah well yeah so you guys both have
this thing mapped out at least like
you've started mapping it out how to pay
for it the value-added tax well we're
saving already with social welfare
programs and then also the economic
stimulus that this is going to bring
forth you list started listing out these
new economic measurements yes is another
pillar and for example like mental
health we don't really run around trying
to analyze how much giving somebody a
freedom dividend would help their mental
health how much it would help their
nutrition how much it would decrease
their hospital visit decrease
incarceration and this this is expensive
stuff yeah yeah yeah so the big problem
and we have a few problems but like one
major problems that were guided almost
solely by GDP stock market prices and
profitability and the issue is that with
AI and new technologies those things are
just going to keep on going up and up
well not the stock when I mean it's
actually it's not goodness
but GDP is gonna keep going up even as
more and more Americans get displaced
you know I mean if you have like trucks
magically drive themselves that's like a
boon to GDP because you can get the same
work done without having to spend all
this money on cupid's but is that going
to be good for human wellbeing and a lot
of communities it's gonna be devastating
for human wellbeing so we need new
measurements that actually correspond to
human well-being
things like median income and wealth
levels of engagement with work mental
health and freedom from substance abuse
childhood success rates environmental
quality proportion of elderly and
quality situations so you can map these
things and say hey like we need to start
driving our economy towards human
wellbeing we need to make the market
serve us as opposed to having us all
serve the market because if it's us all
serving the market we are going to be
screwed because the market is going to
zero out the truck drivers it's going to
zero out the counts it's going to zero
out a lot of people upcoming AI is just
now hitting a point where it's going to
be able to assume the roles of hundreds
of thousands of call center workers and
bookkeepers and a lot of other things
that we have a lot of people doing right
now so so we need to have new
measurements for the economy that
correspond our well-being and then start
driving in that direction and the great
thing here is that this free up these
corporations to start doing things that
help people right now I know CEOs and
board members and they say my hands are
tied because I must optimize for one
variable like shareholder yeah quarterly
profitability shareholder value like
which are tied together so if there's
something else I can maybe get away with
it like one quarter about things are
going really well I can like do
something on the side and be like it was
good PR so we need to fundamentally
change the way that the goalposts are
set up if we want to reorient towards an
economy that will serve us in what is
again the greatest technological shift
in human history yeah the real lining of
the goalposts is like right now this
rock is so small it just takes 40 days
to sail around this rock
and the geopolitical leadership is kind
of overthrowing the we are one mentality
and the prioritization of markets is
overthrowing the humanity yes and these
things being paired together they're
making the goal posts about money and
about geopolitical leadership and
ownership and and and and control and
things like that which I think a lot of
people are racing towards but at the
same time it's putting a back seat on
humanity putting a back seat on the
mentality of shifting the goalposts a
little bit towards humanity what would
that do how would that change the world
for us and you know you're also working
on a digital Social Credit in that
direction as well which you know this is
another really cool pillar it acts as
kind of you know you're doing some token
ah mcc's here well so you have to look
at the the issues on the ground because
startup guy I'm always like okay there's
like the stuff in the boardroom and the
you know the whiteboard and then it's
like what's happening on the ground so
what's happening on the ground right now
is that again more and more American men
are leaving the workforce and men tend
to deteriorate it without work we
include myself because I you know I'm a
guy and I resemble this the first thing
we tend to do is play a lot of video
games so except 5% of this now freed up
time goes to video again this is like a
lost meaning or purpose in life so now
what do we turn to yeah just an idle
dude like the the progression seems to
go by the numbers because I'm a very
data-driven guy it's a lot of video
games
it works well in your 20s but then you
start getting sad in your 30s and then
when you start getting sad in your 30s
you go draw all stop start to be you
know like violence and criminality and
early death that's like the the general
progression without work sounds [ __ ]
horrible
come on it's not that bad
well data there's too many people on the
planet well you know it's this
disintegration that that happens I mean
it's unlikely that it's going to be you
know just in the Primus of people's
homes eventually I mean but so I just
want to point out that this is like by
the numbers this different situation for
men and women idle women do not
disintegrated antisocial behaviors in
the same ways so you have to look at
like the ground floor and say okay
hundreds of thousands of former truck
drivers who now you're sick okay here's
some money but that doesn't sound
problem of what what you do all day
because people need structure
fulfillment here piss work so if we say
to the market being like hey market like
value these people it's going to be very
very difficult because the markets like
I don't really need these people like at
least the way the monetary-market the
way the monetary-market so so we have to
do is if you have these new goals for
the economy then you can say you know
what if you nurture a child volunteering
the community help your neighbor give
someone a ride repair a boiler like any
of those things that move move the
society's goalposts along like install
solar panels work at infrastructure then
we're going to reward you time banking
time banking yeah it's based on the
system called time banking that's in
effect in a couple hundred communities
around the country where if you do
something for someone then you get a
time dollar and then you can say hey I
got this time now I can give it to you
and then you have to do something for me
and then people someone's like okay so
you create all these touch points in the
economy that are independent of skill
level that it's just like anyone can
show up and staff your garage sale or
babysit your kid you know like they're
different things that people can do and
then you tokenize those activities you
guarantee it and as president I will do
this in 2021 you guarantee a monetary
value and you say look these tokens have
real value like you bring them to a bank
will give you a dollar for every like
ten social credits but the beauty of it
then is that you will tax their
Redemption and so people will not redeem
it very often they'll bill they'll do is
they'll just build social credits and
then they'll use the social credits with
each other they'll go to businesses that
will be rewarding positive behavior and
want to be seen as like hey like you
know we love it when people volunteer in
the community so if you come here social
credits and then they get your credits
and trade it to the government so that
all these things that can be done and
you can build this parallel economy
around pro-social activities that's
accessible for people and at every point
the skill ladder that is the vision yeah
that's what we have to
because if we listen to the
monetary-market for too long they're not
gonna value these things like
volunteering and there I'm gonna value
taking care of kids taking care of
elderly my wife right now is home with
our two boys who are five and two she
works harder than I do and about the
market value of her work is zero zero
you know yeah and well I guess
technically if you had to hire somebody
else to take care of your two kids
during that time the market value of
that would be thirty fifty bucks an hour
or whatever for two kids yeah I mean you
could get nannies and and whatnot though
you know there is a difference yeah and
you know there are many things to
they're similar like if you you know if
you and if you look at the way like the
market values for example home health
care aids like taking care your aging
parent you'd be like oh I could pay
something to do that right now the
market rate for that is twenty two
thousand dollars a year and there's a
turnover one hundred percent like pretty
much no one wants to do that job of
taking care of the elderly where because
we remunerated at very very low levels
and so what's happening in a lot of
these contexts is you look at it and the
market tries to seek like the lowest
price point that it can get away with
because you know and and but that causes
its own set of problems and friction so
the the goal for us has to be to
invigorate some of these activities for
a couple of reasons one we need them
because our society is disintegrating
like as we're sitting here were force
participation down our life expectancy
has declined for the last two years
because of a surge in suicides and drug
overdoses or seven Americans are dying
of opiates every this mental health
shit's crazy yeah and it's gonna get
worse if we don't figure out the
automation how we yes it's all tied
together yes where you have Americans
getting pushed into this mindset of
scarcity where they don't have the
bandwidth process things rationally and
then they become more impulsive they
make lesser decisions they get angrier
and more like you know xenophobic and
the rest of it I mean if this sounds
familiar this is exactly what we're
going through right now this is a giant
automation story and so we have to start
owning the problem and then have real
solutions that are going to be massive
if that's the generational challenge but
that's why I'm running for president
to galvanize energy around real
solutions instead of the the garbage
stop gaps that are being presented
you've laid it out pretty well and it's
it's gonna require more than you to get
it done what our what I what are the
first you know 2020 how do you actually
put it into legislation and get it
rolling well certainly the big do is the
freedom dividend where you me around
everyone else gets a thousand bucks a
month and I'm happy to say that's
actually very very doable
all you need is a majority of Congress
there's a wave I become president
there's a Democratic Congress there'll
be a real appetite for this because
people will start accepting that you
know that this is not like it was before
and like it's not like well you know new
jobs just gonna magically appear that
pay people a certain amount so so the
path is very clear I just need to win
and become president and and the
campaign grows everyday because
Americans are waking up but certainly if
anyone wants to help with that the
website is yang 2020 calm you can just
google my name Andrew yang I'm very glad
to say we had contributions from around
the country because people know that
that this time is different we need to
get our acts together very very fast and
it's good that you're getting donations
from a lot of these retail or truck
driving yeah yeah that's good that
people are seeing that and recognizing
it's also crazy that the same people
that got their manufacturing jobs taken
away that there was a you know the
Donald Trump was able to figure out how
to talk to them and get them to vote for
him because he wanted to bring those
back and the the more I guess sensical
idea is to be like let robots do those
jobs and let's return you let's give you
freedom dividends let's talk about
social credits let's do this in a
different way so then you've got to work
you got a lot of work ahead of you in
Iowa and New Hampshire so this is a this
is a way for you to become a top
candidate for the Democratic Party and
therefore your message is communicated
on the larger stages on your to getting
elected yeah so support from around the
country
we need to get our national polling
numbers up to a certain range in order
for me to be in the big stage the
debates and the early states count extra
so it's Iowa New Hampshire and then
South Carolina and Nevada and then
California's number five so so fun nice
hourglass yeah 15 minute class well
that's fun like those 15 minutes that
makes sense yeah yeah cuz the cortisol
at a quarter glass yeah yeah I used to
call it an hourglass too
yeah so we need we need people in early
states again energized we need people
around the country we need people to
spread the word to their friends and say
look we need bigger solutions we need
the freedom dividend we need to value
humanity we need to build a new economy
that puts human goals and values first
as opposed to treating us all like
economic inputs and doing the Machine
because over time the economic inputs
model is going to break down it's
breaking down right now it's bringing
down right now people aren't being
valued well I think that that's the
thing you know these are these are
fantastic ideas but this whole system
has to break down before we can
implement them no one's gonna say yeah
let's do it
until they're forced to do it people
hang on to what they have they don't
want anybody to take it away from them
and they don't want to share they don't
want to volunteer you know this is this
is this is just what I see in my 51
years you know you talk about humanity
having value on humanity people don't
even respect themselves you know there's
there's a lot of truth and substance of
what you're saying because America
historically
has needed the crisis to respond and the
thing that I would say that gives me
optimism is that this is like the
opposite of climate change in terms of
what you ask a people it's like when
there's climate change you're like hey
this is gonna be really bad so like do
all these things for me and we're gonna
like have to regulate things in cost
friction and you know that that's that's
life then people like oh I don't wanna
deal with that but on this one it's like
look existential level threat coming
AI software machines robots and so the
solution is I want to give you $1,000
it's not is that like and I'm gonna take
something away from you it's like and I
want to give you money yeah yeah and
then people will be like huh I'm not
sure if the Asian man is right about the
robots and software but I'd like money
so it's like it's like the opposite of
like the asking people to make a
sacrifice it's like and we need to treat
you better because like big transitions
coming and let's you know let's start
treating people like humans and this
policy passed the House of
Representatives in 1971 under Richard
Nixon this was interesting when you talk
yeah Martin Luther King was for it
Milton Friedman was for it it it became
this club and it stumbled in the Senate
because the Democrats wanted a higher
income threshold it's been in effect in
Alaska for 36 years on a Republican
governor and is wildly popular it's
improved children's nutrition it's
created thousands of jobs it's made
income inequality go down so like this
is not out of the realm of possibility
at all it's like a thousand economist
signed the letter saying this would be
great for the economy in 1970 and it's
been in effect in one state it's just a
state that none of us pays attention to
because it's really cold and a little
far away but it's a Republican state and
they're they're a massive libertarian
and conservative support for this
because there's something very very
deeply conservative about the freedom
dividend it's like look don't give the
government the money so they can do
whatever it's gonna do give you the
money give you the money give me the
money and then we will decide what to do
because we are the owners and
shareholders of this society the same
way a company declares a dividend we're
all like genius like management this
come this country can declare a dividend
for us and it can easily afford it
yeah so what do you think today did I
turn you around on this because one
question one answer just raises another
question it's tough I just don't feel
that yeah I just don't feel that humans
at this stage of the game are
the big catastrophe has to happen before
anything gets done these are just all
visions of the future yes we are gonna
get there we are going to achieve these
things but billions of people need to
die period very dark man that's the
truth the universe is dead space is dark
and exactly what we have to try and
prevent and preempt because to me this
revolution happens I have a good way the
bad way and the bad way may be
irreversible
like it's one of the things that
frustrates me about some people in this
conversation where some people say
universal basic income is inevitable but
we shouldn't be doing it right now
because of whatever and then I'm like
look if it's inevitable you can't time
it perfectly buy some like you know
unknown standard if you go too early
what is the downside you get more time
to adjust you get to build new
institutions like people can adapt if
you go too late it might be catastrophic
like it's not like after the great
trucking riots of 2026 then you're like
oh like here's universal basic income
and then all the truckers go home happy
it's like you have to try and make the
big moves to ease the transition because
it's not like communities or individuals
or families just magically reintegrate
like right right now there's a
disintegration happening and it's very
very clear by the numbers again surging
suicides seven Americans dying of
opiates every hour more Americans on
disability than work in construction
they you can like record low numbers of
businesses being started people getting
married people moving having children
pretty much any positive act of optimism
is that a record or historic low I mean
our [ __ ] is coming apart and so the
question is like whether we can come
together and say hey let's let's have
like a meaningful response to this or
like you're saying we get there the bad
way but if we get there the bad way
there's probably no coming back like the
institutions need to come together
quickly and on this one - it's like like
I'm suggesting something it's gonna make
most everyone's lives better like people
say like what's life gonna be like after
universal basic income like now just
less miserable I mean it's like like we
can't put that together so so I'm very
optimistic because it's gonna help
people and you know you get enough
people activated around that you can win
ooh you almost can't be pessimistic
because you wouldn't get the election
and you know that's that's that's a real
thing today didn't today's day and age
you can't be pessimistic you won't win
the election this is you teaching about
venture for America to Obama in 2012
stimulating entrepreneurship explaining
the importance of the center so so it
says Barack was very very interested he
was like tell me more tell me more yeah
I've actually I've actually spent a bit
of time with him because I was like
appointed to a couple of different like
presidential engagements it was you know
so great good it's great fun I got to
introduce my wife to him at the White
House like my in-laws liked me more for
about a month for about a month for
about a month you know now my in-laws
are you know takes a little while yeah
so you know I asked you this earlier and
I think it's still important you know
there's like Scandinavia's going on
they're doing tests with the universal
basic income different parts of the
world are exploring what it would be
like different parts of the world are
exploring other things like sesame
credit in China or genetic engineering
without regulations so people are kind
of tweaking around with things you know
ron was saying was pointing at this
earlier just this idea of maybe it's
maybe it is totally fine you know we are
talking about prioritizing humanity over
the markets and putting ubi in early and
saving people's lives and like yeah
their likelihood livelihoods and then
the this alternatives like well what
happens we're like aren't we fighting
against evolution the survival of the
fittest right now there are these groups
of people on the planet that have
accumulated so much wealth they have
they have made so much
impact and the other ones might not have
and it's a roll of the dice for you to
be born in the place that has up that is
just less socioeconomic status than
another and so is it is it our
responsibility is it the responsibility
of high SES to figure out how to funnel
money through things like this value out
of tax and universal basic income and
figure that out or should they just
specie eight and go like I'll be in the
poor class and I just won't be able to
keep up right and just like go specie
eight go colonize the cosmos and maybe
your kids and their kids and whatnot
maybe will like just like leave it
behind well I mean I know you know
people that have that point of view and
to me the whole thing is just so dumb
because like let's say I'm you know a
rich person in San Francisco do I really
think that you know society can
disintegrate and that like my life will
be just as like easy and happy and
frictionless as it is now like of course
not like if I have to hire bodyguards
and get a bulletproof car and like you
know take my kids out of school and get
like a bunker somewhere and like you
know I have to redecorate the bunker you
know and like have to live with my
constant anxiety and fear because
studies have shown that people who are
at the top of unequal societies are less
happy than people who are at the top of
more equal societies so to me it's just
like enlightened self-interest to be
like look let's try and keep society
whole and it's not like the the like the
survival of the fittest thing I mean
like you know it's like it's not like
people stopped having kids by the
numbers I mean right now is we're
sitting here forty percent of American
children are born to a single or an
unmarried mother it's so bad and it's
it's not good and so and it just goes to
show that it's not like all of a sudden
there's like a total curtailment of like
reproduction I mean that's not the case
you know so but but there is something
very fundamental there which is like if
you follow just like the economic
rationale being like I'm more than a
billion like you're
zero then you wind up in very very dark
dystopian realities very very quickly
yeah and as much as we can talk about
the utopia and the dystopia I think that
many people would rather push towards
like you said enlightened self-interest
of pushing towards more of a being at
the top of a higher baseline for
everybody and just being a top more
inclusion yeah there's like the
humanists more or less thing it's like
the right thing to do it's more like I'm
still a human being and an American and
a parent and like the rest of it and
then there's just the practical it's
like riots are bad like you know like
private security forces literally
there's one person riots are not bad
they will do they will do they will try
to get away with whatever they can as
long as people are satisfied but the
fact of the matter is there's a lot of
people that are waking up you talked
about people waking up they know that
the game is rigged there's something
behind this that's not gonna change
until people start dying until people
get bashed in their skulls with metal
pipes not at all bring that [ __ ] on well
as soon as we can exactly it's like oh
snap
even the guy behind the camera wants to
buy someone's going no not me not at all
I'm not gonna do that I'm a I'm a
pacifist I a lot of I'm a lover not a
fighter but I'm well aware that like
that's there are visions that are being
painted out and Iran's vision is that
there is a metal pipe that could come
smashing to someone's head because
they're rioting because they don't have
access to food or water or work or
anything that they need and they're
getting lied to and they're getting
cheated and they're they're being
deceived it's it's it's a terrible game
and and that that is the case where a
society is more fragile than many people
would like to believe and the people at
the top again you can have the humanists
like benign motivation which I'm glad to
say there are people that really do have
that in their hearts but then there's
even like just the enlightened
self-interest being like look this is a
much better way to me to go there was
actually a guy
who was like trying to pay a consultant
to be like hey if everything goes bad
how do I make sure my security forces
don't turn on me in the bunker because
at that point like you know like how do
I know like what's like so that's the
kind of eventualities are literally
playing out it's much much better for us
to come together
yeah then yeah yeah then to wind up in
the bunker being like how do I know my
security guys not gonna like shoot me in
the head so cyber attack that's
happening on the robotic bodyguards it's
not from a different person that's
trying to kill me either there's there's
so much to unpack in the in the youto be
like the you're right that it seems as
though the right direction is this
direction but then the further it's like
how do we get there and you know you
have laid out some plans for us to get
there I want to ask you a couple
questions on the way out that we ask our
guests jerem what do you think we're
alone in the cosmos um
it's highly unlikely to me that we're
alone in the cosmos there's certainly
life someplace else you know the
question is whether that life is like
you like flying saucer type of life
where it's you know like fly over but
this there's life someplace else yeah
and they're paying very close attention
in this conversation we're having right
yeah yeah but I will say though that
this campaign is our chance to advance
the species because if you imagine us
implementing this here in the United
States it would follow suit in many
other countries right now CSS backwards
so this campaign can advance the species
yeah I do think that efforts like what
we're discussing right now these sort of
collective movements can progress
humanity to hopefully get past these
Fermi filters that prevent civilizations
from flourishing in the cosmos yes it
says one yes there's life someplace else
there almost have to be do you think
that this is a simulation I guess I saw
that for the topic oh my gosh I don't
think this is a simulation why don't
oh
because it is a good question
he's I haven't seen like I know there
was like this argument that it is a
simulation here's the data but I just
feel like you are a numbers man
I am a numbers man and is a possibility
I would not dismiss the possibility
simulation and I would not but and I
also him there are times when when it
does feel like you're walking and like
steps that have been like lay down in
front of you in the sand I mean there
there there's like sometimes that sense
but but I still believe it's us and
we're doing it and we're choosing in or
making happen do you believe in free
will you know yeah I do believe in free
will to a point like I do think it's not
that that many of the virtues that we
praise in people it's like oh that's
just like something you know because
certainly to the extent I'm capable of
of anything like there are a lot of
things that went into it in terms of my
parentage and you know it's like it's so
so even the things where I think I'm
choosing like they're probably a lot of
things that you know we're just my
wiring or at the fact that you know my
dad like pushed me in a certain way or
whatever just and then what do you
thinks the most beautiful thing in the
world Andrew you know I mean there's
gonna sound cheesy but I am a dad and I
do get a thrill when are there my son's
like hugs me or like jumps on my back or
you know like looks me in the eyes and
you know anyone who's a parent like if
you have that situation I'm I will say
that one of the main reasons I'm running
for president is that I became a parent
you know almost six years ago now and
that process led me to see just how
rough it is for most people under most
circumstances to be a parent and you
know in my mind I was cocky I was like
whatever I'm like you know like educated
I have some resources like you know
we're married like there's gonna be a
breeze like freakin you know people with
much much less have kids and they figure
it out or whatever
when we had yeah I was like oh my gosh
it's like anyone else gids can relate to
this but I got exposed to the world of
like dependence and weakness and
friction in a way that just made me much
more I think kind of what most people
are experiencing and like it's real and
it'll destroy many many families and
people
I like how you reference the moments in
time when your kids are jumping on your
back or looking at you and your eyes and
that being so beautiful and like how
you're also referencing this in deeper
sense of empathy for other people and
less fortunate rolls of the dice because
when we do build that deeper sense of
empathy it does prioritize humanity over
markets it does prioritize doing things
like universal basic income for the
world and figuring out how to
economically prosperous and and and even
spiritually prosperous spiritually yeah
through the greatest technological shift
that humanity's facing right now
so Andrew yang what a freaking pleasure
thanks Alice it's been great to be here
thank you for so much for coming on to
the show no problem please do check out
yang 2020 dot-com definitely give that a
check also the new book the war on
normal people please check that out as
well take a look at that join us in the
conversation guys think about it go and
talk to two other people about it talk
about the freedom dividend go and have
more conversation about it going to
check out more information on Yang 2020
com join us comment below with your
thoughts we'd love to continue building
the community subscribe also consider
joining us on patreon so continue
growing this impacting more people with
it thanks everybody for tuning in and
let's build a beautiful future together
much love
[Music]
[Music]
you